[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit mini
serien ihnen allen einen schönen
sonntagabend norbert könig springt
springt es auch ohne bringt uns vor die
auf den stand der dinge sturm wird
morgen spielen später noch eine rolle so
wir schauen uns jetzt die themen des
tages an
diplomatischen eklat nach umstrittenen
aussagen zum ukraine konflikt tritt der
chef der deutschen marine zurück aber
kiew bleibt verärgert
bleiben die korona maßnahmen vor der
neuen bund länder konferenz hält
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst pauschale
lockerungen für verfrüht und
wieder nichts mit einem grand slam
erfolg des olympiasiegers wieder
verliert im achtelfinale der australian
open
der deutsche marineschiff suggerierte
mit problematischen äußerungen respekt
und verständnis für russlands
präsidenten putin der rücktritt ist zwar
schon erfolgt der schaden inmitten einer
international angespannten
sicherheitslage aber angerichtet über
den torpedo aus den eigenen reihen für
deutschlands diplomatische bemühungen im
schwelenden ukraine konflikt ines trams
fühlte er sich unbeobachtet oder wollte
er provozieren ein auftritt des
deutschen marine inspekteurs in indien
endete im eklat die furcht der
westlichen staaten vor einem angriff
russlands auf die ukraine hält
vizeadmiral k achim schönbach für
nonsens verständnis äußert er für die
motivation des russischen präsidenten
putin
er will respekt und mein gott jemand im
respekt entgegenzubringen kostet was
nichts also würde man mich fragen es ist
leicht ihm den respekt zu geben den
erfordert und den er vermutlich auch
verdient
schönbach tritt noch am samstagabend
zurück dem botschafter der ukraine lang
das nicht für ihn stehen schön was
aussagen symptomatisch für eine in
ukrainischen augen halbherzige deutsche
politik erfordert erneut defensivwaffen
die glaubwürdigkeit der bundesrepublik
stellt aus unserer sicht im moment
gerade auf dem spiel man muss nicht nur
reden auch handeln können und ihres
handelns ist heute schon gefragt doch
die ampel koalition will weiterhin keine
waffen liefern verweist auf die deutsche
geschichte und den koalitionsvertrag ich
bin der meinung wir sollten jetzt erst
mal durchatmen ruhe bewahren ich
persönlich habe immer gesagt dass ich
mir vorstellen könnte
defensives militärisches material zu
liefern das sehen teile der
bundesregierung anders die
verteidigungsministerin akzeptiert den
rücktritt schönbach umgehend ein
lazarett will deutschland im februar
richtung ukraine schicken
zufriedenstellen wird dass die ukraine
wohl nicht
und wir blicken jetzt in die ukraine und
zwar in die zweitgrößte stadt des landes
ist nicht weit weg von der russischen
grenze dort ist anna heißt für uns anna
was denken die menschen über
deutschlands rolle im aktuellen konflikt
ja wir stehen hier in hf die stadt die
sollten die russen tatsächlich angreifen
als erstes an die russen fallen könnte
so sagte es präsident selensky vor
wenigen tagen und die menschen hier sind
wütend sie sind sauer auf den sie sind
sauer auf den marinechef und seine
äußerungen und sie sind aber auch sauer
auf die absage deutschlands
verteidigungswaffen hierher zu liefern
wir haben am nachmittag drehen können
mit aktivisten die die frontsoldaten im
donbass mit hilfsgütern beliefert und
die männer sagten es wäre ein wichtiges
signal wenn deutschland waffen hierher
schicken würde denn je mehr waffen in
der ukraine sein umso unwahrscheinlicher
sei ein angriff der russen einer der
männer reagierte sehr emotionale auf
meine nachfrage
er sagte zu mir deutschland das sei doch
das gesicht europas und er fragte mich
wieso wollen sich die deutschen nicht
ganz klar zu uns positionieren und wieso
wollen sich die deutschen nicht
entscheiden ob krieg oder frieden
herrsche schönen dank nach hanna faist
über die wachsenden spannungen mit
russland zeigt sich aber nicht nur die
ukraine besorgt sondern auch schweden
die schwedische regierung lässt panzer
auffahren weil sie einen zitat
bewaffneten angriff nicht ausschließen
kann in der ostsee waren zuletzt mehr
russische militär schiffe unterwegs als
üblich vor allem auf der strategisch
wichtigen insel gotland verstärkt
schweden die präsenz und von dort
berichtet hannah hebestreit
hinter den historischen festungsmauern
der inselhauptstadt wyss be leben die
menschen wie in einer filmkulisse
gotland ist ein beliebtes urlaubsziel in
der ostsee auf dem seit tagen das
militär kontrolliert mit panzern und
schwer bewaffneten soldaten gibt sich
schweden abwehrbereit the last days the
work wie der in den letzten tagen haben
wir uns einen überblick über die lage
verschaffen
das gibt uns einen größeren spielraum
für reaktionen sollte irgendwas
passieren
dafür haben sie soldaten und ausrüstung
vom festland auf die insel gebracht
sollte russland neben der ukraine
plötzlich auch die baltischen staaten
ins visier nehmen könnte gotland
strategisch wichtig werden befürchten
forscher im umfeld des schwedischen
verteidigungsministeriums
control mitteilung
wenn man die insel gotland kontrolliert
kamera vollendete tatsachen schaffen für
alle operationen die man vor hat die
operation statuen zu dürfen auf gotland
wo sie vor allem vom geschäft mit den
urlaubern leben sorgt die vorstellung
plötzlich brennpunkt des weltgeschehens
zu werden für unsicherheit
ich glaube nicht dass großen kommen und
land holen haben nicht auf der insel
sieht man die verstärkung des gotland
regiments er als ein zeichen der
wachsamkeit und nicht als vorbote eines
möglichen konflikt in der ostsee
vor der morgigen bund länder runde setzt
der bundeskanzler schon mal den ton es
sei nicht angebracht die regeln zu
lockern wir brauchen keine kurskorrektur
so scholz in der süddeutschen zeitung
passend dazu warnt der expertenrat der
bundesregierung vor einer überlastung
des gesundheitssystems zu steigenden
hauptstadt zahlen und wonach es bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
aussieht thomas konsum
ein sonntag in der schlange berlin
checkt sich auf corona pcr tests sind in
landeseigenen zentren noch kostenlos
etwa wenn ivan app angeschlagen hat und
das tut sie in der hauptstadt immer
öfter denn regional gibt es nirgendwo in
deutschland höhere instanzen der wert im
bezirk mitte etwa
2845 auch bundesweit schnell die zahlen
empor das rkw verzeichnet gut 85.000
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden und
sieben tage incidents liegt erstmals
über 800 einen noch viel höheren anstieg
erwartet das beratergremium der
bundesregierung zitat es können in der
spitze sieben tages instanzen von
mehreren tausend regional erreicht
werden jetzt ganz genau messen wo es
ganz wichtig ist ziel eines
beschlussvorschlags für die bund länder
konferenz morgen pcr tests werden
demnach priorisiert wohl gable gruppen
und beschäftigte der kritischen
infrastruktur bevorzugt ebenso bei der
kontakt nach verfolgung die impfkampagne
soll verstärkt werden und lockerungen
angesichts der vergleichsweise moderaten
lage in krankenhäusern noch nicht so der
politische kurs aber auch keine
strengeren regeln aktuell ist der rat
der experten der wissenschaft nicht dass
wir verschärfen sollen sondern dass wir
das maßnahmenpaket das aktuell gültige
ist und was gewirkt hat gegen einen sehr
steilen anstieg beibehalten sollen
dennoch auch über öffnungen will man
morgen beraten
großveranstaltungen draußen möglich wenn
nicht gefährdet ist was die gesellschaft
am laufen hält
dem wahrscheinlich größten protestmarsch
an diesem wochenende gegen korona
maßnahmen gab es in brüssel rund 50.000
menschen zogen zunächst friedlich durch
die straßen der belgischen hauptstadt am
mittag gab es dann aber zahlreiche
gewaltsame auseinandersetzungen zwischen
demonstranten und der polizei
so wir machen jetzt den sprung zum sport
mit norbert und du geht es auch gleich
weiter mit den sprüngen es drängt sich
förmlich auch nach diesem
bemerkenswerten wochenenden titisee
neustadt
denn dort hat karl geiger genau wie
gestern das weltcup springen gewonnen
seine führung im gesamtweltcup ausgebaut
und noch mal bestätigt er ist ein heißer
medaillenkandidat für die winterspiele
in peking karl geiger schwebt auf einer
erfolgswelle auch eine verkürzung des
anlaufs unmittelbar vor ihm lässt ihn
kalt aus luke 7 und mit weniger
anfangsgeschwindigkeit siegel der auf
143 meter exakt die weite der slowenin
lange shack vor ihm aus höherer
anfahrtsposition
rio kobayashi geigers großer konkurrent
im gesamtweltcup und führender nach dem
ersten durchgang landet deutlich vor der
grünen linie
der japaner fällt noch auf platz vier
zurück geiger feiert seinen vierten
saisonsieg
zwei wochen vor den olympischen spielen
ist auch markus eisenbichler in
medaillenform landet als dritter wieder
auf dem podium karl geiger feiert seinen
zweiten sieg binnen 24 stunden auf der
vorher ungeliebten schanze im
schwarzwald
die deutschen biathleten haben heute als
team überzeugt obwohl sie nicht in
bestbesetzung angetreten sind im
staffelwettbewerb von antholz erreichte
das quartett roman rees philipp horn
david zobel und lukas fratzscher ohne
strafrunde und bin nur vier nachladern
platz drei weltmeister norwegen gewinnt
souverän mit fast zwei minuten vorsprung
vor dem team aus russland
für tennisprofi alexander zverev war es
dagegen in melbourne ein schwarzer
sonntag aus der traum vom ersten grand
slam sieg schon nach dem achtelfinale
wie in früheren tagen mussten mehrere
schläger dran glauben zverev im
bildvordergrund völlig außer form beim 3
2 6 6 7 und 3 6 gegen den kanadier denis
schapowalow auf der nun anstatt es wäre
spaniens superstar rafael nadal
herausfordern darf
und dass bundesliga sonntagsspiel
leipzig ging wolfsburg 20 dann fielen
dank in norbert wir blicken noch
gemeinsam aufs wetter im westen und
süden ein paar größere auflockerungen
sonst meist stark bewölkt oder neblig
trübe vor allem im osten etwas
sprühregen die höchstwerte dann zwischen
drei und neun grad wir empfehlen das
heute journal um 21.45 mit marietta
slomka haben sie noch einen 5
sonntagabend morgen einen erfolgreichen
start in die neue woche dann mit jana
paradies an dieser stelle auf eis
gott habe ich was vergessen schnell
rüber zu berlin direkt jetzt und theo
koll entschuldigung